why do we have crime we have crime
because of this the white supremacist
patriarchy which is why video just went
viral
there is a spate of of shoplifting going
on in san francisco there's a video of a
security guard watching
a guy not a straight white male
definitely a black guy
just with a giant bag filling up the bag
with stolen goods hopping on a bicycle
security guard is just filming and tries
to get the bag but the guy just
goes away and just rides right out of
the store it's not gonna be any
consequences
so yeah see ya bye-bye
17 walgreens stores have had to close
according according to the new york
times because the scale of
theft is so insane right now because
there are no consequences
and you know in that guy's defense the
the shoplifters defense
he has been told by the entire
establishment
that it is his right to shoplift that he
is it's look it's wrong it's objectively
wrong it's a sin
to steal you're imperiling your your
soul
if you steal but he's not told that
according to our new religion with its
new liturgical calendar of
pride month in juneteenth according to
our new understanding of
sin which derives from racism instead of
sin itself it's not this guy's fault
he's the victim
society owes him whatever goods he's
i don't think he was stealing them for
personal use by the way he was just
shoveling them into a bag because he's
going to go sell them
this is not a this is not a starving man
stealing a loaf of bread
this guy certainly does not need to
steal but he's choosing to do it
and it's not entirely i mean he needs to
take responsibility but it's not
entirely his fault because the whole
society is telling he has every right to
as the powers break down as society
breaks down
hey before you retire and shut off
all of your electronics so that you can
fully celebrate
the feast day the national feast day of
juneteenth the holiest day of the entire
liturgical calendar
according to the modern libs as of like
five minutes ago
before you do that subscribe ring that
bell
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcasts google play spotify
stitcher wherever you go
get the michael noel show podcast
subscribe leave a five star review and
then most important of all
pre-order speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now
for pre-order head on over see you next
[Music]
[Music]
time